So let's see if we understood the impact of branch predictors on performance.
We will consider the old Pentium 4 Prescott processor which has an extremely
deep pipeline. It fetches then does 29 stages worth of work and
only then it resolves branches. It of course uses branch prediction and
is capable of executing multiple instructions per cycle. So that in a program,
where about 20% of all instructions are branches, only 1% of branches might
be mispredicted, and let's say that that gives us a CP1 program of 0.5.
So the question for you is, if we had a slightly worse predictor, so
that 2% of branches are mispredicted in the program,
how would that change the CPI? What would the CPI be?